PROFESSOR: So the handouts will
be just the problem set 8
solutions, of which you already
have the first two.
Remind you problem set 9 is
due on Friday, but we will
accept it on Monday if that's
when you want to
hand it in to Ashish.
And problem set 10 I will hand
out next week, but you won't
be responsible for it.
You could try it if
you're so moved.
OK.
We're in the middle
of chapter 13.
We've been talking about
capacity approaching codes.
We've talked about a number of
classes of them, low density
parity check, turbo, repeat
accumulate, and I've given you
a general idea of how the sum
product decoding algorithm is
applied to decode these codes.
These are all defined on graphs
with cycles, in the
middle of which is a large
pseudo random interleaver.
The sum product algorithm is
therefore done iteratively.
In general, the initial observed
information comes in
on one side, the left side or
the right side, and the
iterative schedule amounts to
doing first the left side,
then the right side, then the
left side, then the right
side, until you converge,
you hope.
That was the original turbo
idea, and that continues to be
the right way to do it.
OK.
Today, we're actually going to
try to do some analysis.
To do the analysis, we're going
to focus on low density
party check codes, which are
certainly far easier than
turbo codes to analyze,
because they
have such simple elements.
I guess the repeat accumulate
codes are equally easy to
analyze, but maybe not as
good in performance.
Maybe they're as good,
I don't know.
No one has driven that
as far as low density
parity check codes.
Also, we're going to take
a very simple channel.
It's actually the channel for
which most of the analysis has
been done, which is the Binary
Erasure Channel, where
everything reduces to a
one-dimensional problem, and
therefore we can do things
quite precisely.
But this will allow me to
introduce density evolution,
which is the generalization of
this for more general channels
like the binary input added
white Gaussian noise channel,
if I manage to go fast enough.
I apologize today, I
do feel in a hurry.
Nonetheless, please ask
questions whenever you want to
slow me down or just get some
more understanding.
So, the Binary Erasure Channel
is one of the elementary
channels, if you've ever taken
information theory,
that you look at.
It has two inputs and
three outputs.
The two inputs are 0 and 1, the
outputs are 0 and 1 or an
erasure, an ambiguous output.
If you send a 0, you can either
get the 0 correctly, or
you could get an erasure.
Might be a deletion, you just
don't get anything.
Similarly, if you send
a 1, you either
get a 1 or an erasure.
There's no possibility of
getting something incorrectly.
That's the key thing
about this channel.
The probability of an erasure
is p, regardless of whether
you send 0 or 1.
So there's a single parameter
that governs this channel.
Now admittedly, this is not
a very realistic channel.
It's a toy channel in
the binary case.
However, actually some of the
impetus for this development
was the people who were
considering packet
transmission on the internet.
And in the case of packet
transmission on the internet,
of course, you have a long
packet, a very non-binary
symbol if you like, but if you
consider these to be packets,
then on the internet, you either
receive the packet
correctly or you fail
to receive it.
You don't receive it at all, and
you know it, because there
is an internal party check
in each packet.
So the q-ary erasure channel is
in fact a realistic model,
and in fact, there's a company,
Digital Fountain,
that has been founded and is
still going strong as far as I
know, which is specifically
devoted to solutions for this
q-ary erasure channel for
particular kinds of scenarios
on the internet where you want
to do forward error correction
rather than repeat
transmission.
And a lot of the early work on
the analysis of these guys--
Luby, Shokrollahi,
other people--
they were some of the people
who focused on low density
party check codes immediately,
following work of Spielman and
Sipser here at MIT, and said,
OK, suppose we try this on our
q-ary erasure channel.
And they were able to get very
close to the capacity of the
q-ary erasure channel, which
is also 1 minus p.
This is the information
theoretic capacity of the
binary channel.
It's kind of obvious that it
should be 1 minus p, because
on the average, you get 1 minus
p good bits out for
every bit that you send in.
So the maximum rate you could
expect to send over this
channel is 1 minus p.
OK.
Let's first think about maximum
likelihood decoding on
this channel.
Suppose we take a word from a
code, from a binary code, and
send it through this channel,
and we get some erasure
pattern at the output.
So we have a subset of the
bits that are good, and a
subset that are erased
at the output.
Now what does maximum likelihood
decoding amount to
on this channel?
Well, the code word that we sent
is going to match up with
all the good bits
received, right?
So we know that there's going to
be at least one word in the
code that agrees with
the received
sequence in the good places.
If that's the only word in the
code that agrees with the
received word in those places,
then we can declare it the
winner, right?
And maximum likelihood
decoding succeeds.
We know what the channel is, so
we know that all the good
bits have to match up
with the code word.
But suppose there are 2 words
in the code that match up in
all the good places?
There's no way to decide
between them, right?
So basically, that's what
maximum likelihood decoding
amounts to.
You simply check how many
code words match the
received good bits.
If there's only one,
you decode.
If there's more than one, you
could flip a coin, but we'll
consider that to be a
decoding failure.
You just don't know, so you
throw up your hands, you have
a detected decoding failure.
So in the case of a linear code,
what are we doing here?
In the case of a linear
code, consider the
parity check equations.
We basically have n minus k
parity check equations, and
we're trying to find how many
code sequences that solve
those parity check equations.
So we have n minus k equations,
n unknowns, and
we're basically just trying
to solve linear equations.
So that would be one
decoding method for
maximum likelihood decoding.
Solve the equations.
If you get a unique solution,
you're finished.
If you get a space of solutions,
so dimension one or
more, you lose.
OK?
So we know lots of ways of
solving linear equations like
Gaussian elimination, back
propagation/back substitution
(I'm not sure exactly
what it's called).
That's actually what we will
be doing with low density
parity check codes.
And so, decoding for the binary
ratio channel you can
think of as just trying to
solve linear equations.
If you get a unique solution,
you win, otherwise, you fail.
Another way of looking at it
in a linear code is what do
the good bits have to form?
The erased bits have to
be a function of the
good bits, all right?
In linear code, that's just
a function of where
the good bits are.
We've run into this
concept before.
We called it an information
set.
An information set is a subset
of the coordinates that
basically determines the
rest the coordinates.
If you know the bits in
that subset, then you
know the code word.
You can fill out the rest of
the code word through some
linear equation.
So basically, we're going to
succeed if the good bits cover
an information set, and we're
going to fail otherwise.
So how many bits do we need to
cover an information set?
We're certainly going
to need at least k.
Now today, we're going to be
considering very long codes.
So suppose I have a
long (n,k) code.
I have an (n,k) code, and I
transmit it over this channel.
About how many bits are
going to be erased?
About pn bits are going
to be erased, or (1
minus p) times n.
We're going to get
approximately--
law of large numbers--
(1 minus p) times n unerased
bits, and this has to be
clearly greater than k.
OK, so with very high
probability, if we get more
than that, we'll be able to
solve the equations, find a
unique code word.
If we get fewer than that,
there's no possible way we
could solve the equations.
We don't have enough left.
So what does this say?
This says that k over n, which
is the code rate, has to be
less than 1 minus p in order
for this maximum likelihood
decoding to work with a linear
code over the binary erasure
channel, and that is consistent
with this.
If the rate is less than 1 minus
p, then with very high
probability you're going
to be successful.
If it's greater than 1 minus p,
no chance, as n becomes 1.
OK?
You with me?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, in general,
they're not, and the first
exercise on the homework
says take the 844 code.
There's certain places where if
you erase 4 bits, you lose,
and there are other places
where if you
erase 4 bits, you win.
And that exercise also points
out that the low density
parity check decoding that
we're going to do, the
graphical decoding, may fail
in a case where maximum
likelihood decoding
might work.
But maximum likelihood decoding
is certainly the best
we can do, so it's clear.
You can't signal at a rate
greater than 1 minus p.
You just don't get more than 1
minus p bits of information,
or n times (1 minus p) bits of
information in a code word of
length n, so you can't possibly
communicate more than
n times (1 minus p)
bits in a block.
OK.
So what are we going
to try to do to
signal over this channel?
We're going to try using a low
density parity check code.
Actually, I guess I did
want this first.
Let me talk about both of
these back and forth.
Sorry, Mr. TV guy.
So we're going to use a low
density parity check code, and
initially, we're going to assume
a regular code with,
say, left degree is 3 over
here, right degree is 6.
And we're going to try to decode
by using the iterative
sum product algorithm with
a left right schedule.
OK.
I can work either
here or up here.
What are the rules for sum
product update on a binary
erasure channel?
Let's just start out, and walk
through it a little bit, and
then step back and develop
some more general rules.
What is the message coming
in here that we
receive from the channel?
We're going to convert it
into an APP vector.
What could the APP vector be?
It's either, say, 0, 1 or 1,
0, if the bit is unerased.
So this would be-- if we get
this, we know a posteriori
probability of a 0 is a
1, and of a 1 is a 0.
No question, we have
certainty.
Similarly down here, it's a 1.
And in here, it's 1/2, 1/2.
Complete uncertainty.
No information.
So, we can get--
those are our three
possibilities off the channel.
(0,1), (1,0), (1/2, 1/2).
Now, if we get a certain bit
coming in, what are the
messages going out on each
of these lines here?
We actually only need
to know this one.
Initially, everything inside
here is complete ignorance.
Half, 1/2 everywhere.
You can consider everything
to be erased.
All right.
Well, if we got a known bit
coming in, a 0 or a 1, the
repetition node simply
says propagate
that through all here.
So if you worked out the sum
product update rule for here,
it would basically say, in this
message, if any of these
lines is known, then this line
is known and we have a certain
bit going out.
All right?
So if 0, 1 comes in,
we'll get 0, 1 out.
It's certainly a 1.
Only in the case where all of
these other lines are erased--
all these other incoming
messages are erasures-- then
we don't know anything,
then the output
has to be an erasure.
All right?
So that's the sum product update
rule at a equals node.
All right?
If any of these d minus 1
incoming messages is known,
then the output is known.
If they're all unknown, then
the output is unknown.
You're going to find, in
general, these are the only
kinds of messages we're ever
going to have to deal with.
Either, we're basically going
to take known bits and
propagate them through
the graph--
so initially, everything is
erased, and after awhile, we
start learning things.
More and more things become
known, and we succeed if
everything becomes known
inside the graph.
All right?
So it's just the propagation of
unerased variables through
this graph.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No.
So they're not only known,
but they're correct.
And like everything else, you
can prove that by induction.
The bits that we receive from
the channel certainly have to
be consistent with the
correct code word.
All these internal constraints
are the constraints of the
code, so we can never generate
an incorrect message.
That's basically the hand
waving proof of that.
OK.
So we're going to propagate
either known bits or erasures
in the first iteration.
And what's the fraction of these
lines that's going to be
erased in a very long code?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Its going to be p.
All right?
So initially, we have fraction
p erased and fraction 1 minus
p which are good.
OK.
And then, this, we'll take this
to be a perfectly random
interleaver.
So perfectly randomly,
this comes out there.
OK?
All right, so now we have
various messages
coming in over here.
Some are erased, some are known
and correct, and that's
the only things they can be.
All right, what can we do
on the right side now?
On the right side, we have to
execute the sum product
algorithm for a zero sum
node of this type.
What is the rule here?
Clearly, if we get good data
on all these input bits, we
know what the output bit is.
So if we get five good ones over
here, we can tell what
the sixth one has to be.
However, if any of these is
erased, then what's the
probability this
is a 0 or a 1?
It's 1/2, 1/2.
So any erasure here
means we get no
information out of this node.
We get an erasure coming out.
All right, so we come in here,
and if p is some large number,
the rate of this code is 1/2.
So I'm going to do a simulation
for like p equals a
little less--
small enough so that this code
could succeed, 0.4--
so the capacity is
0.6 bits per bit.
But if this is 0.4, what's the
probability that any 5 of
these are all going
to be unerased?
It's pretty small.
So you won't be surprised to
learn that the probability of
an erasure of coming back--
call that q--
equals 0.9 or more,
greater than 0.9.
But it's not 1.
So for some small fraction of
these over here, we're going
to get some information, some
additional information, that
we didn't have before.
And this is going to propagate
randomly back, and it may
allow us to now know some of
these bits that were initially
erased on the channel.
So that's the idea.
So to understand the
performance of
this, we simply track--
let me call this, in general,
the erasure probability going
from left to right, and this,
in general, we'll call the
erasure probability going
from right to left.
And we can actually compute what
these probabilities are
for each iteration under the
assumption that the code is
very long and random so that
every time we make a
computation, we're dealing
with completely fresh and
independent information.
And that's what we're
going to do.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: When they come from
the right side, they're either
erased or they're consistent.
I argued before, waving my
hands, that these messages
could never be incorrect.
So if you get 2 known messages,
they can't conflict
with each other.
Is that your concern?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Because you're randomly
connecting [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
so it might be that one of the
plus signs gave you an
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], whereas
another plus sign gave you a
proper message.
And they both run back
to the same equation.
PROFESSOR: Well, OK.
So this is pseudo random,
but is chosen for
once and for all.
It determines the code.
I don't re-choose it every time,
but when I analyze it,
I'll assume that it's random
enough so that the bits that
enter into any one calculation
are bits that I've never seen
before, and therefore can be
taken to be entirely random.
But of course, in actual
practice, you've got a fixed
interleaver here, and you
have to, in order
to decode the code.
But the other concern here
is if we actually had the
possibility of errors, the pure
binary erasure channel
never allows errors.
If this actually allowed a 0 to
go to a 1 or a 1 to go to
0, then we'd have an altogether
different situation
over here, and we'd have to
simply honestly compute the
sum product algorithm and what
is the APP if we have some
probability of error.
And they could conflict, and
we'd have to weigh the
evidence, and take the
dominating evidence, or mix it
all up into the single
parameter
that we call the APP.
All right.
So let me now do a
little analysis.
Actually, I've done this
a couple places.
Suppose the probability
of erasure here--
this is the q right
to left parameter.
Suppose the probability of q
right to left is 0.9, or
whatever, and this is the
original received message from
the channel, which had an
erasure probability of p.
What's the q left to right?
What's the erasure probability
for the outgoing message?
Well, the outgoing message is
erased only if all of these
incoming messages are erased.
All right, so this is simply
p times q right to
left, d minus 1.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Assuming it's
a long random code, so
everything here is
independent.
I'll say something else about
this in just a second.
But let's naively make that
assumption right now, and then
see how best we can
justify it.
What's the rule over here?
Here, we're over on the right
side if we want to compute the
right to left.
If these are all erased with
probability q left to right,
what is the probability that
this one going out is erased?
Well, it's easier to compute
here the probability of not
being erased.
This is not erased only if all
of these are not erased.
So we get q right to left.
One minus q right to left is
equal to 1 minus q left to
right, to the d minus 1.
And let's see, this is d right,
and this is d left.
I'm doing it for the
specific context.
OK, so under the independence
assumption, we can compute
exactly what these evolving
erasure probabilities are as
we go through this left
right iteration.
This is what's so neat about
this whole thing.
Now, here's the best argument
for why these are all
independent.
Let's look at the messages
that enter into, say, a
particular--
this is computing q left
to right down here.
All right, we've got something
coming in, one bit here.
We've got more bits coming in
up here, and here, which
originally came from bits
coming in up here.
We have a tree of computation.
If we went back through this
pseudo random but fixed
interleaver, we could actually
draw this tree for every
instance of every computation,
and this would be q left to
right at the nth iteration,
this is--
I'm sorry.
Yeah, this is q left to right at
the nth iteration, this is
q right to left at the n minus
first iteration, this is q
left to right at the n minus
first iteration, and so forth.
Now, the argument is
that if I go back--
let's fix the number of
iterations I go back here--
m, let's say, and I want to do
an analysis of the first m
iterations.
I claim that as this code
becomes long, n goes to
infinity with fixed d lambda,
d rho, that the probability
you're ever going to run into
repeated bit or message up
here goes to 0.
All right?
So I fix the number
of iterations I'm
going to look at.
I let the length of the
code go to infinity.
I let everything be chosen
pseudo randomly over here.
Then the probability of seeing
the same message or bit twice
in this tree goes to 0.
And therefore, in that limit,
the independence assumption
become valid.
That is basically the
argument, all right?
So I can analyze any
fixed number of
iterations in this way.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, yes.
Good.
So this is saying the girth
is probabilistically--
so limit in probability going
to infinity, or it's also
referred to as the locally
tree-like assumption.
OK, graph in the neighborhood
of any node--
this is kind of a map of the
neighborhood back for a
distance of m--
we're not ever going to
run into any cycles.
Good, thank you.
OK, so under that assumption,
now we
can do an exact analysis.
This is what's amazing.
And how do we do it?
Here's a good way of doing it.
We just draw the curves of these
2 equations, and we go
back and forth between them.
And this was actually a
technique invented earlier for
turbo codes, but it works very
nicely for low density parity
check code analysis.
It's called the exit chart.
I've drawn it in a somewhat
peculiar way, but it's so that
it will look like the exit
charts you might see an in the
literature.
So I'm just drawing q right to
left on this axis, and q left
to right on this axis.
I want to sort of start in the
lower left and work my way up
to the upper right, which
is the way exit
charts always work.
So to do that, I basically
invert the axis and take it
from 1 down to 0.
Initially, both of these--
the probability is one that
everything is erased
internally on every edge, and if
things work out, we'll get
up to the point where nothing
is erased with high
probability.
OK, these are our 2 equations
just copied from over there
for the specific case of left
degree equals 3 and right
degree equals 6.
And so I just plot the curves
of these 2 equations.
This is done in the notes, and
the important thing is that
the curves don't cross, for
a value of p equal 0.4.
One of these curves depends on
p, the other one doesn't.
So this is just a simple little
quadratic curve here,
and this is a fifth order
curve, and they look
something like this.
What does this mean?
Initially, the q right
to left is 1.
If I go through one iteration,
using the fact that I get this
external information--
extrinsic information--
then q left to right becomes
0.4, so we do to the outer.
Now, I have q left to right
propagating to the right side,
and at this point, I get
something like 0.922, I think
is the first one.
So the q right to left
has gone from
1 down to 0.9 something.
OK, but that's better.
Now, with that value of q, of
course I get a much more
favorable situation
on the left.
I go over to the left
side, and now I get
some p equal to--
this is all done
in the notes--
0.34.
So I've reduced my erasure
probability going from left to
right, which in turn, helps me
out as I go over here, 0.875,
and so forth.
Are you with me?
Does everyone see
what I'm doing?
Any questions?
Again, I'm claiming this is
an exact calculation--
or I would call it
a simulation--
of what the algorithm does
in each iteration.
First iteration, first full,
left, right, right left, you
get to here.
Second one, you get to
here, and so forth.
And I claim as n goes to
infinity, and everything is
random, this is the
way the erasure
probabilities will evolve.
And it's clear visually that if
the curves don't cross, we
get to the upper right corner,
which means decoding succeeds.
There are no erasures anywhere
at the end of the day.
And furthermore, you go and
you take a very long code,
like 10 to the seventh bits,
and you simulate it on this
channel, and it will behave
exactly like this.
OK, so this is really a good
piece of analysis.
So this reduces it to
very simple terms.
We have 2 equations, and of
course they meet here at the
(0,0) point.
Substitute 0 in here,
you get 0 there.
Substance 0 here,
But if they don't meet anywhere
else, if there's no
fixed point to this iterative
convergence, then decoding is
going to succeed.
So this is the whole question:
can we design 2 curves that
don't cross?
OK.
So what do we expect
now to happen?
Suppose we increase p.
Suppose we increase p to 0.45,
which is another case that's
considered in the notes,
what's going to happen?
This curve is just a simple
quadratic, it's going to be
dragged down a little bit.
We're going to get some
different curve, which is just
this curve scaled by
0.45 over 0.4.
It's going to start here,
and it's going to
be this scaled curve.
And unfortunately, those
2 curves cross.
So that's the way it's going
to look, and now, again, we
can simulate iterative decoding
for this case.
Again, initially,
we'll start out.
We'll go from 1, 0.45 will be
our right going erasure
probability.
We'll go over here, make
some progress, but
what's going to happen?
We're going to get stuck
right there.
So we find the fixed point.
In fact, this simulation is
a very efficient way of
calculating what the fixed point
of these 2 curves are.
Probably some of you are
analytical whizzes and can do
it analytically, but
it's not that easy
for a quintic equation.
In any case, as far as decoding
is concerned--
all right, this code doesn't
work on an erasure channel
which has an erasure probability
of 0.45.
It does work on one that has an
erasure probability of 0.4.
That should suggest
to you-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes, so this code
doesn't get to capacity.
Too bad.
So I'm not claiming that a
regular d left equals 3, d
right equals 6 LDPC code
can achieve capacity.
There's some threshold for p,
below which it'll work, and
above which it won't work.
That threshold is somewhere
between 0.4 and 0.45.
In fact, it's 0.429 something
or other.
So this design approach will
succeed it's near capacity,
but I certainly don't
claim this is a
capacity approaching code.
I might mention now something
called the area theorem,
because it's easy to do
now and it will be
harder to do later.
What is this area here?
I'm saying the area above
this curve here.
Well, you can do that simply
by integrating this.
It's integral of p times
q-squared dq from 0 to 1, and
it turns out to be p over 3.
Believe me?
Which happens to be p over
the left degree.
Not fortuitously, because this
is the left degree minus 1.
So you're always going to get
p over the left degree.
And what's the area
under here?
Well, I can compute--
basically change variables to
1 minus q, q prime, and 1
minus q is q prime over here,
and so I'll get the same kind
of calculation, 0 to 1, this
time q to the fifth over pq,
which is 1/6, which not
fortuitously is 1 over d right.
So the area here is p over
3, and the area here is--
under this side of
the curve is--
that must be 5/6.
Sorry, so the area under
this side is 1/6 so
it's 1 minus this.
It's clearly the big part,
so this is 5/6.
All right.
I've claimed my criterion for
successful decoding is that
these curves not cross.
All right, so for successful
decoding, clearly the sum of
these 2 areas has to be
less than 1, right?
So successful decoding: a
necessary condition is that p
over d_lambda --
let me just extend this
to any regular code--
plus 1 minus 1 over d_rho
has to be less than 1.
OK, what does this sum out to?
This says that p has to be less
than d_lambda over d_rho,
which happens to 1
minus r, right?
Or equivalently, r less than 1
minus p, which is capacity.
So what did I just prove
very quickly?
I proved that for a regular low
density parity check code,
just considering the areas under
these 2 curves and the
requirement that the 2 curves
must not cross, I find that
regular codes can't possibly
work for a rate any greater
than 1 minus p, which
is capacity.
In fact, the rate has to be less
than 1 minus p, strictly
less, in order for there to--
unless we were lucky enough just
to get 2 curves that were
right on top of each other.
I don't know whether that
would work or not.
I guess it doesn't work.
But we'd need them to be
just a scooch apart.
OK, so I can make an inequality
sign here.
OK, well that's rather
gratifying.
What do we do to improve
the situation?
OK, one--
it's probably the first thing
you would think of
investigating maybe at this
point, why don't we look at an
irregular LDPC code?
And I'm going to characterize
such a code by--
there's going to be some
distribution on the left side,
which I might write
by lambda_d.
This is going to be the
fraction of left
nodes of degree d.
All right, I'll simply let that
be some distribution.
Some might have degree 2, some
might have degree 3.
Some might have degree 500.
And similarly, rho_d
is the fraction of
right nodes, et cetera.
And there's some average degree
here, and some average
degree here.
So this is the average degree,
or the typical degree.
This is average left degree,
this is average right degree.
If I do that, then
the calculations
are done in the notes.
I won't take the time to do them
here, but basically you
find the rate of the code is 1
minus the average left degree
over the average right degree.
OK, so it reduces to
the previous case
and the regular case.
Regular case, this is 1 for one
particular degree and 0
for everything else.
It works out.
If I do that and go through
exactly the same analysis with
my computation tree, now I
simply have a distribution of
degrees at each level of the
computation tree, and you will
not be surprised to hear what I
get out as my left to right
equations, is I get out
some average of this.
In fact, what I get out now is
that q left to right is the
sum over d of--
this is going to be lambda_d
times p times q right to left
to the d minus 1.
Which again reduces to the
previous thing, if only one of
these is 1 and the rest are 0.
So I just get the--
this is just an expectation.
This is the fraction
of erasures.
I just count the number of times
I go through a node of
degree d, and for that fraction
of time, I'm going to
get this relationship, and so
I just average over them.
That's very quick.
Look at the notes for a detailed
derivation, but I
hope it's intuitively
plausible.
And similarly, 1 minus q right
to the left is the sum over d
of rho_d, 1 minus q left to
right to the d minus 1.
OK, this is elegantly
done if we
define generating functions.
We do that over here.
I've lost it now so I'll
do it over here.
So what you'll see in the
literature is generating
functions to find is lambda_x
equals sum over d of lambda_d
x to the d minus 1.
And rho of x equals sum over d,
rho_d, x to the d minus 1.
And then these equations
are simply written as--
this is p times lambda of q
right to left, and this is
equal to rho of 1 minus
q left to right.
OK, so we get nice, elegant
generating function
representations.
But from the point of view of
the curves, we're basically
just going to average
these curves.
So we now replace these
equations up here by the
average equations.
This becomes p times lambda of
q right to left, and this
becomes rho of 1 minus
q left to right.
OK, but again, I'm going to
reduce all of this 2 curves,
which again I can use
for a simulation.
And now I have lots of
degrees of freedom.
I could change all these lambdas
and all these rhos,
and I can explore the space,
and that's what's Sae-Young
Chung did in his thesis, not
so much for this channel.
He did do it for this channel,
but also for additive white
Gaussian noise channels.
And so the idea is you try to
make these 2 curves just as
close together as you can.
Something like that.
Or, of course, you can
do other tricks.
You can have some of these--
you can have some bits
over here that go
to the outside world.
You can suppress some
of these bits here.
You can play around
with the graph.
No limit on invention.
But you don't really have
to do any of that.
So it becomes a curve fitting
exercise, and you can imagine
doing this in your thesis,
except you were
not born soon enough.
The interesting point here is
that this now becomes--
the area becomes p over
d_lambda-bar, again,
proof in the notes.
This becomes 1 minus
1 over d_rho-bar.
And so again, the
area theorem--
in order for these curves not to
cross, we've got to have p
over d_lambda-bar plus 1 minus
1 over d_rho-bar, less than
the area of the whole exit
chart, which is 1.
We again find that--
let me put it this way, 1
minus d_lambda-bar over
d_rho-bar is less than 1 minus
p, which is equivalent to the
rate must be less than the
capacity of the channel.
So this is a very nice,
elegant result.
The area theorem says that no
matter how you play with these
degree distributions in an
irregular low-density parity
check code, you of course can
never get above capacity.
But, it certainly suggests that
you might be able to play
around with these curves such
that they get as close as you
might like.
And the converse of this is
that if you can make these
arbitrarily close to each other,
then you can achieve
rates arbitrarily close
to capacity.
And that, in fact, is true.
So simply by going to irregular
low-density parity
check codes, we can get as close
as we like, arbitrarily
close, to the capacity of the
binary erasure channel with
this kind of iterative
decoding.
And you can see the kind
of trade you're
going to have to make.
Obviously, you're going to have
more iterations as these
get very close.
What is the decoding process
going to look like?
It's going to look like very
fine grained steps here, lots
of iterations, but--
all right.
So it's a 100 iterations.
So it's 200 irritations.
These are not crazy numbers.
These are quite feasible
numbers.
And so if you're willing to
do a lot of computation--
which is what you expect,
as you get close
to capacity, right--
you can get as close to capacity
as you like, at least
on this channel.
OK, isn't that great?
It's an easy channel, I grant
you, but everything here is
pretty simple.
All these sum product
updates--
for here, it's just a matter
of basically snow point
propagating erasures.
You just take the
known variables.
You keep computing as many
as you can of them.
Basically, every time an edge
becomes known, you only have
to visit each edge
once, actually.
The first time it becomes known
is the only time you
have to visit it.
After that, you can just
leave it fixed.
All right, so if this has a
linear number of edges, as it
does, by construction, for
either the regular or
irregular case, the complexity
is now going
to be linear, right?
We only have to visit
each edge once.
There are only a number of
edges proportional to n.
So the complexity of this whole
decoding algorithm-- all
you do is, you fix as many edges
as you can, then you go
over here and you try to fix as
many more edges as you can.
You come back here, try to fix
as many more as you can.
It will behave exactly as this
simulation shows it will
behave, and after going back
and forth maybe 100 times--
in more reasonable cases, it's
only 10 or 20 times, it's a
very finite number of times--
you'll be done.
Another qualitative aspect of
this that you already see in
the regular code case--
in fact, you see it very
nicely there-- is that
typically, very typically, you
have an initial period here
where you make a rapid progress
because the curves
are pretty far apart, then you
have some narrow little tunnel
that you have to get through,
and then the
curves widen up again.
I've exaggerated it here.
So OK, you're making great
progress, you're filling in,
lots of edges become known, and
then for a while it seems
like you're making no progress
at all, making very tiny
progress on each iteration.
But then, you get through
this tunnel, and boom!
Things go very fast.
And for this code,
it has a zero--
the regular code has a zero
slope at this point, whereas
this has a non-zero slope.
So these things will go boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom as you
go in there.
So these guys at Digital
Fountain, they called their
second class of codes,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], tornado
codes, because they
had this effect.
You have to struggle and
struggle, but then when you
finally get it, there's a
tornado, a blizzard, of known
edges, and all of a sudden, all
the edges become known.
Oh by the way, this could
be done for packets.
There's nothing--
you know, this is a repetition
for a packet, and this is a
bit-wise parity check
for a packet.
So the same diagram works
perfectly well for packet
transmission.
That's the way they use it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Right.
So this chart makes
it very clear.
If you're going to get this
tornado effect, it's because
you have some gap in here.
The bigger the gap, the further
away you are from
capacity, quite quantitatively.
So I just--
this is the first year I've been
able to get this far in
the course, and I think
this is very much
worth presenting because--
look at what's happened here.
At least for one channel, after
50 years of work in
trying to get to Shannon's
channel capacity, around 1995
or so, people finally figured
out a way of constructing a
code and a decoding algorithm
that in fact has linear
complexity, and can get as close
to channel capacity as
you like in a very
feasible way, at
least for this channel.
So that's really where we want
to end the story in this
class, because the whole class
has been about getting to
channel capacity.
Well, what about
other channels?
What about channels
with errors here?
So let's go to the symmetric
input binary
channel, which I--
symmetric, sorry-- symmetric
binary input channel.
This is not standardized.
The problem is, what you really
want to say is the
binary symmetric channel, except
that term is already
taken, so you've got to
say something else.
I say symmetric binary
input channel.
You'll see other things
in the literature.
This channel has 2 inputs: 0
and 1, and it has as many
outputs as you like.
It might have an
erasure output.
And the key thing about the
erasure output is that the
probability of getting there
from either 0 or 1 is the
same, call it p again.
And so the a posteriori
probability, let's write the
APPs by each of these.
The erasure output is always
going to be a state of
complete ignorance,
you don't know.
So there might be one output
like that, and then there will
be other outputs here
that occur in pairs.
And the pairs are always going
to have the character that
their APP is going
to be 1 minus--
I've used p excessively here.
Let me take it off of here
and use it here--
for a typical other pair, you're
going to have 1 minus
pp, or p 1 minus p.
In other words, just looking
at these 2 outputs, it's a
binary symmetric channel.
The probability of p
of cross over and 1
minus p of being correct.
And we may have pairs that are
pretty unreliable where p is
close to 1/2, and we
may have pairs that
are extremely reliable.
So this 1 minus p prime, p
prime, where p prime might be
very close to 0.
But the point is, the outputs
always occur in these pairs.
The output space can be
partitioned into pairs such
that, for each pair, you have a
binary symmetric channel, or
you might have this singleton,
which is an erasure.
And this is, of course, what we
have for the binary input
additive white Gaussian
noise channel.
We have 2 inputs, and now we
have an output which is the
complete real line, which has
a distribution like this.
But in this case, 0
is the erasure.
If we get a 0, then the
probability of the APP message
is (1/2,1/2).
And the pairs are
plus or minus y.
If we get to see y, then the
probability of y given 0, or
given one, that's the same pair
as the probability of
minus y given--
this is, of course, minus 1,
plus 1 for my 2 possible
transmissions here.
Point is, binary input added
white Gaussian noise channel
is in this class.
It has a continuous output
rather than a discrete output.
But there's a key symmetry
property here.
Basically, if you exchange
0 for 1, nothing changes.
All right, so the symmetry
between 0 and 1.
That's why it's called
a symmetric channel.
That means you can easily prove
that for the capacity
achieving input distribution is
always (1/2,1/2), for any
such channel.
If you've taken information
theory, you've seen this
demonstrated.
And this has the important
implication that you can use
linear codes on any symmetric
binary input channel without
loss of channel capacity.
Linear codes achieve capacity.
OK, whereas, of course, if this
weren't (1/2,1/2), then
linear codes couldn't possibly
achieve capacity.
Suppose you have
such a channel.
What's the sum product
updates?
The sum product updates become
more complicated.
They're really not hard
for the equality sign.
You remember for a repetition
node, the sum product update
is just the product of basically
the APPs coming in
or the APPs going out.
So all we've got to do
is take the product.
It'll turn out the messages in
this case are always of the
form p, 1 minus p--
of course, because they're
binary, and so
has to be like this--
so we really just need
a single parameter p.
We multiply all the p's, and
that normalize correctly, and
that'll be the output.
For the update here, I'm sorry
I don't have time to talk
about it in class, but there's
a clever little procedure
which basically says take
the Hadamard Transform
of p, 1 minus p.
The Hadamard Transform in
general says, convert this to
the pair of a plus
b, a minus b.
So in this case, we convert it
to a plus b is always 1, and a
minus b is, in this
case, 2p minus 1.
Works out better, turns
out this is actually
a likelihood ratio.
Take the Hadamard Transform,
then you can use the same
product update rule as
you used up here.
So do the repetition node
updates, which is easy--
so it says just multiply all the
inputs component-wise in
this vector, and then take the
Hadamard Transform again to
get your time domain
or primal domain,
rather than dual domain.
So you work in the dual
domain, rather
than the primal domain.
Again, I'm sorry.
You got a homework problem on
it, after you've done the
homework problem, you'll
understand this.
And this turns out to
involve hyperbolic
tangents to do these.
These Hadamard Transforms turn
out to be taking hyperbolic
tangents, and this is called the
hyperbolic tangent rule,
the tanh rule.
So there's a simple way to do
updates in general for any of
these channels.
Now, you can do the
same kind of
analysis, but what's different?
For the erasure channel, we only
had 2 types of messages,
known or erased, and all we
really had to do is keep track
of what's the probability of the
erasure type of message,
or 1 minus this probability,
it doesn't matter.
So that's why I said it
was one-dimensional.
For the symmetric binary input
channel, in general, you can
have any APP vector here.
This is a single parameter
vector.
It's parameterized by p, or by
the likelihood ratio, or by
the log likelihood ratio.
There are various ways
to parameterize it.
But in any case, a single number
tells you what the APP
message is.
And so at this point-- or I
guess, better looking at it in
the competition tree--
at each point, instead of having
a single number, we
have a probability distribution
on p.
So we get some probability
distribution on p, pp of p,
that characterizes where
you are at this time.
Coming off the channel,
initially, the probability
distribution on p might be equal
to y, I think it is,
actually, or p to the minus y,
and you get some probability
distribution on what p is.
By the way, again because of
symmetry, you can always
assume that the all-zero vector
was sent in your code.
It doesn't matter which of your
code words is sent, since
everything is symmetrical.
So you can do all your analysis
assuming the all-zero
code word was sent.
This simplifies things
a lot, too.
p then becomes the probability
which--
well, I guess I've
got it backwards.
Should be 1 minus pp, because
p then becomes the
probability.
If the assumed probability of
the input is a 1, in other
words, the probability
that your current
guess would be wrong--
I'm not saying that well.
Anyway, you get some
distribution of p.
Let me just draw it like that.
So here's pp of p.
There's probability
distribution.
And again, we'll draw it
going from 1 to 0.
So that doesn't go out here.
OK, with more effort, you can
again see what the effect of
the update rule is
going to be.
For each iteration, you have a
certain input distribution on
all these lines.
Again, under the independence
assumption, you get
independently--
you get a distribution for the
APP parameter p on each of
these lines.
That leads--
you can then calculate what the
distribution-- or simulate
what it is on the output line,
just by seeing what's the
effect of applying the
sum product rule.
It's a much more elaborate
calculation, but you can do
it, or you can do it up to
some degree of precision.
This you can't do exactly, but
you can do it to fourteen bits
of precision if you like.
And so again, you can work
through something that amounts
to plotting the progress of the
iteration through here, up
to any degree of precision
you want.
So again, you can determine
whether it succeeds or fails,
again, for regular or irregular
low-density parity
check codes.
In general, it's better
to make it irregular.
You could make it as irregular
as you like.
And so you can see that this
could involve a lot of
computer time to optimize
everything, but at the end of
the day, it's basically a
similar kind of hill climbing,
curve fitting exercise, where
ultimately on any of these
binary input symmetric channels,
you can get as close
as you want to capacity.
In the very first lecture, I
showed you what Sae-Young
Chung achieved in his thesis.
He got the binary input
additive white
Gaussian noise channel.
He got under the assumption of
asymptotically long random codes.
He got within 0.0045 dB
of channel capacity.
And then for a more reasonable
number, like a block length of
10 to the seventh, he
got within 0.040
dB of channel capacity.
Now, that's still a
longer code than
anybody's going to use.
It's a little bit of a stunt,
but I think his work convinced
everybody that we finally had
gotten to channel capacity.
OK, the Eta Kappa Nu
person is here.
Please help her out, and
we'll see you Monday.